oh it's going to be um
glue this month but yeah great show
tonight we're gonna have a good one nope
that's the wrong sketch that's another
mug based sketch i was involved in
it's uh glue this mug
guys i like mugs
hey conan here uh with andy another
edition of behind the nonsense where we
look at
uh some of the sketches that seem to
come to mind after all these years this
next uh sketch we're going to talk about
was uh written
by our own dan cronin good to see you
sir good to see you cones and uh also by
andre dube that's right you two wrote
this sketch i haven't seen it yet i'm
just remembering
uh this is an example of a sketch that
the beauty is how far it goes i think
that's probably fair to say like
absolutely it there's not long enough
perfect length
way too long way way too long and then
there's just going for it in a way that
starts to redeem itself and become kind
of magical this is the type of sketch at
rehearsal where andy who can sometimes
very quickly just go nah and that kills
it this is one of those sketches this
this is one of those sketches where
gotta do my job yeah but this is one of
those sketches where andy goes to you he
looks to you and he goes we gotta do it
yeah
and so quick note uh this uh features
the performing talents of one of the
greats of all time brian stack brian
stack was just a mainstay on the old
late night show he was with us for a
long time with a tonight show
not a long time at the time show he was
with us tonight show and then he was
with us a long time at tbs and then uh
he and his family moved back to new york
and he's working with stephen colbert
where he's quite happy brilliant writer
but uh i just wanted to get that shout
out to brian stack who has always did
such amazing work uh with us let's take
a look at the sketch and then we'll
discuss
i noticed that the eisenhower mug that's
been on my desk for 22 years
just got broken uh somehow and so i'd
like to get it fixed can someone glue
this can just take a second can someone
glue this mug handle oh yeah sure thing
mr o'brien okay all right here we go
[Applause]
larry larry larry that's right larry
yeah okay do you mind gluing that for me
sure all right thanks a lot i just
appreciate it thank you very much
larry
is it larry it's larry that's larry
larry okay i didn't release him uh okay
let's get to business uh there's this
viral video going around that everyone's
been talking
okay well anyway this viral video is
going around that i wanted to show you
guys because it's really
larry
larry can you come out here oh yeah
michelle brian okay what are you doing
back there well i'm just gluing your mug
back together like yes
well that that's cool but you're making
a lot of noise it's so it's very noisy
oh yeah sorry i can make less noise if
you want it less glued
no
okay just do what you got to do but
could you hurry it up if you can you got
to miss o'brien and trust me i know what
i'm doing that's why they hired me okay
i i glue mug candles
yeah there's this viral video that's
what i want to talk about
[Applause]
[Music]
here's your mug mr o'brien all glued
just like you wanted
yeah forget the mug what happened to
larry larry's dead
oh my god yeah we we told him to take
his time that safety comes first but
then larry's exact words were screw
safety conan needs this mug asap
he was my son's godfather
okay wait a minute how long did this guy
work here today was his first day
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay
it took a piece of what is what is what
is all this mr richter we just want to
thank you to you and your family for all
the beautiful flowers and of course the
edible arrangement
well you know it's the least i could do
for larry he's one of the greatest mug
gluers the industry's ever known
without further ado please welcome us
secretary of education helen beaumont
[Music]
thank you
in addition to gluing hollywood mugs for
over 30 years
lawrence jorgensen was a tireless
advocate for musical education
through his program toots for tuts
larry donated woodwind instruments to
over 400 000 students across the united
states
today we welcome several tooting tots
representing the burbank school district
playing an original composition entitled
greatest mug guy ever
please note for most of these students
tonight is their first time picking up a
musical instrument and it's all thanks
to larry
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know i'm sorry those kids are kind
of old to be called tots and
i think they should practice before you
let them on television
you're right this has gone on a little
too long mr o'brien please enjoy this
brief tribute video
hanson garrett will market my beard
kings and queens he came thundering on
his feet
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
jorgensen
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah there was an otter in there
what the hell's going on
the guy just died how did you have time
to make that thing
we're always thinking ahead mr all right
let's trick down okay we're gonna take a
break i'm gonna figure out just what the
hell just happened when we come back
keith urban's here
[Applause]
there is so much to talk about
keith urban that's the funniest part the
funniest part keith urban
the funniest part is keith thurman had
to sit through that
well i have to say i have to say that uh
the purpose or almost the mission
statement of the show from the very
beginning was
imagine people at home seeing this
this went into people's homes absolutely
and they're watching it and my mug
breaks and someone goes to help it and
then this whole thing keeps unfolding
until he's a norse god in a rock band
pre-taped his own pre-tape
somewhere i might have it there's
footage of you at rehearsal when you
come right out of it and you're dabbing
your eyes and you're just
and you're trying to say something and
kona goes what did you say that goes on
so [ __ ] long oh my god that's
hilarious
the fact that that was beamed into
people's homes and it was supported by
these big companies
with all this money i mean general
motors i used to have the same feeling
back at nbc which is we would take all
this money that was generated by shows
that were
really popular like friends and and uh
right down the middle yeah yeah yeah and
we would take all the money that was
generated by that stuff and they would
give us some of it and we would take it
and go thanks a lot and then beam this
stuff that nobody asked for
i mean so many of us
started watching you because of that
because
there were so many things that started
off with mundane little things a person
coming through and you don't know what's
going to happen i used to always call it
this is a schedule i have to be mr
mooney because you do need in comedy
the oliver hardy or the mr mooney's the
cranky banker in uh lucille ball's i
think second or third tv show and he was
like lucille
what are you doing lucille and so i
would go from a silly person to when
it's called for uh guys what's yeah do
we have to shouldn't those children
they're not really
shouldn't they practice their lucille
but yeah i always thought it would be
good to have a montage of you over the
years just going who the hell are you
yeah because
so many of our sketches are i would say
60 of our
non-topical silly pure silly late at
night sketches are me conducting
business yeah saying well anyway we've
got a great oh hello
excuse me who are you
uh please i'm trying to do a show yeah
and then they would make an outrageous
request like all i want to do is build
my birdhouse can you help me and i'd say
well
we've got mary tyler moore coming up but
okay or keith urban or keith urban yeah
i will say one thing about andre dubuche
who i've written a lot of stuff with he
doesn't love to collaborate that's not
his thing he likes to write his own [ __ ]
yeah but when you sit down with him you
write something with him he's the most
fun generous it's never gonna be hedged
in by fear from a writer's perspective
to do a sketch like that that's the
you're using the meat of the entire
building you have scott chronix getting
you those norse outfits that little
barge that stack was put on was actually
a miniature so they built a little
like a pool and we we pushed that and
then green screamed them onto that yeah
we have all the props you have the crew
guys it was just so much basically money
that could have put a deserving child
through college yes
he went to create every [ __ ] reality
one of those kids playing those
recorders that's probably 800 bucks a
kid you know like just right there like
that's you know okay i didn't know that
i was sitting down with the accounting
department well what i want to say about
a bit like that is that
it represents i think something personal
to
us as the people that we are the kind of
people that we are who end up being on
tv making this kind of thing which is
we're weird and this is weird and this
is going out and part of that going out
is like knowing there's a lot of people
who are going to go what the [ __ ] is
that why am i watching this what is
going on here perhaps there's an ounce
of like you know that's what kind of is
makes it fun for us and for the people
that really like it but it's us calling
out to those other weirdos who know that
they're different you know because
that's like that sketch is
the definition of not for everyone yeah
you know no that's what it is exactly us
that sketch is a uh is a very strange
club with very odd food and really loud
music yeah yeah
wait no so you wrote a sketch called
fixing no i did not that's not true that
was wow suddenly oh i'm sorry that one
was where it's caught yes it was me so
there's where's conan's mug is missing
yes there's a fix this mug and there's a
glue this month no yes no yes welcome to
the nuremberg trial you seem very no
there's you seem very defensive this mug
and fix this mug are the same sketch no
further questions your honor you can't
say that as well